Are you planning out your next application
architecture and don't know if you want to try
something new? As cloud native developers we often
have to make decisions about what to use on our
front-end, back-end, and that middle tier which must
include some choices around databases here. For
today's topic, I want to talk through Redis as your
next pick for your database technology here. Hello
my name is Jamil Spain. I'm a Brand Technical
Specialist in the U.S. Financial Services Market.
When I made my decisions on how to solution
Redis in my architectures, I used three simple
categories to categorize their importance and how
it rates for me and, they were the flexibility
that it offers me, the implementation ,how easy
is it to implement, and of course the deployment,
the most important thing. Now one thing to keep
top of mind about Redis is that it is an in-memory
data store.
That's to say that everything you put in sits in
memory so it has very, very quick and easy access
to it, but the role that it plays great is as a
cache, and it can also function as a full-fledged
data store if you would like to. And of
course if you want to dig even deeper
there are certainly some messaging capabilities
there as well. Now, when we talk about cash what
exactly do you mean? Well, that can be any type
of structures from strings, to hashes, to lists.
I think we all get the picture about what can
fit uh definitely into this database there,
and in your architecture, and when i think about
it as a mobile, developer web, developer, myself,
in practice, I know there are some times when I
want to just put a set of data somewhere quickly
to access it later, and this is really where
this shines, and so it really helped me to know
categorize it when I needed a quick place to cache
something very, very easy Redis was a strong check
mark uh there as well. Let's actually put a check
mark there now implementation there are certainly
all types of SDKs are available from C
to JavaScript, I'll just do J.S., to Java,
to Python. Be sure to check redis.io for all
the SDKs that are available, but that was a very
important factor to me. Depending on the
language of choice that I want to develop, with
how easy is it to actually integrate and implement
the infrastructure there, the data structures that
I want to save? Also, one thing that was a big
bonus for me is that Redis can also is compatible
with a lot of IoT architectures. Whether that's
the Raspberry Pi, I'll do some abbreviation here,
and also or any other armed base solutions there
as well. It also means that it's really relatively
easy to implement as a supporting program
into a lot of architectures that I want to do,
and then finally, how does this work for
deployment? Well I make my decisions in dev.
How is it for easiest for me to make single
instances to prove out my case, of course
and see how it works and how it functions, but
definitely as I get something more mature and
I want to advance up to my production
or more production level instances here
it works off the traditional main node and
secondary node model. One thing of note here is,
that what I did like about this is
that as you publish to the main node,
it will do automatic caching replication to the
secondaries. That's not something that I really
have to worry about, and I can scale out adding
more and more replicas, secondary nodes there as
I need to to ensure the resiliency, and that it
will always be available. As we know we want to
make sure if we leverage this as a strong
component of my architecture for caching,
I want to make sure it's going to be resilient
and be up from there. Check mark there. Now
this is just an entry conversation into Redis
as your database choice, feel free to check
redis.io for more. Thank you for your time. If
you have questions please drop us a line below,
and if you want to see more videos like this
in the future please like and subscribe.